so five years ago I told you that I
would show you something if we ever
cross paths at a junket again and it was
at the Kingsmen junket and something
happens there so I have a little clip
for you to watch here and I want to show
you what happens so you just press play
it's an awesome team I really like that
before I go I kind of made a joke of it
too big okay where is it it's it's right
here oh my god I said I would do it I do
not lie I adore that thing so some I
said to myself before I asked you if the
handwriting isn't nice or into is not
written correctly I'm not gonna do it
and it's fine you you've read it you
order beautifully and now I have a
tattoo that I will have the rest of my
life and love right after I what I think
I went something like two days after and
I did it and Jurassic Park is my
favorite movie of all time and hold on
to your butt's is the line that I repeat
most often so I said if I ever met him I
would do that I love it oh I'll write
any quotes you ever need it's gonna
tattoo it I got to think of a really
good one yeah deal no it's not on my
bike just next to you but yeah yeah
close enough thank you so much for your
time
[Music]